and in this series 15 times
i know we keep bringing that up but we
have a long way to go in this game and
one thing
is is you want to keep him off the line
because when he gets to the line that
means capella
is might be in foul trouble here's young
leans
[Applause]
and then when you leave young you know
he's certainly capable of hitting that
shot so fivel picks up his third
personal foul
so he hung with the fake though that was
a good thing he had he had confidence
that he could get the pick now
there's your first move and then here
comes the second move
by tybalt this young guy got a lot of
energy
at six foot five he covers a lot of
ground he has an excellent
intuition about where the passing lane
is and how he can
help his other teammates in half court
defense
but he's on the bench with those three
fouls you see the numbers for young so
far
35 points for trey young in game one 25
of those came in the first half
and young is three or four at the line
tonight and
20 of 22 now for the series he had a
guard on
him and his size was there and he could
have gone strong he's been so good in
in the paint so far in this game harris
six of nine as well
[Applause]
screen and roll and great job by trae
young again to draw
contact this time it's ben simmons that
commits the foul
when you talk about his game his game we
know is three-point shooting out past
30 but this is what makes him so
dangerous
he can get in this is his favorite move
whether it's in the half court offense
or he's coming in transition
he stopped